[Music]
straight ahead
on law and crime daily code breakers
crack one of the most infamous cypress
left
by the zodiac killer how they were able
to unlock this half a century mystery
just through sheer luck and persistence
we ended up coming to the solution
search and rescue teams are looking for
a missing three-year-old boy in ohio
his mother dead her boyfriend arrested
where could nilo be
we don't stop until we cover every base
and
we're here to bring him home a trial
attorney fights back over
accusations he failed to adequately
represent his client
they were lying to sort of fit their
narrative
why a father accused of murdering his
son wants a new trial
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
a clue that has haunted investigators
for decades
has finally been solved law and crimes
chief investigative correspondent brian
ross
has this big break in the zodiac killer
case
thanks brian coming up this week i'm
brian ross investigates
we'll meet the man who helped to break
the coded message sent by the zodiac
serial killer some 51 years ago
the case spawned movies and books and it
was big news at the time
as he terrorized northern california now
after all these years
the zodiac killer's secret coded message
sent to san francisco newspapers
has been broken not by the fbi but by a
team of amateur sleuths
led by david aranczak in roanoke
virginia
oh at that moment it was incredible
because i had been working on this thing
for so long i
had gotten used to the solutions not
going anywhere
and then to see that phrase that was
when i immediately
had that switch in my mind go to oh my
god
this is probably uh on the right track
ransack posted a youtube video showing
how he
and his team actually did it this one
had words like
hope you are trying to catch me and
or the gas chamber at that time the rest
of the plaintext looked like garbage and
nonsense
like many other thousands of solutions
i've seen over the years but these
phrases turned out to be our way into
the real solution
so i plugged those into a z decrypt
using what's called a crib feature
boom suddenly got a really clean message
and the phrase
that wasn't me on the tv show pops out
but after all these years
even cracking the secret code may not be
enough to lead police and the fbi to the
true identity of the killer
former fbi agent and profiler brad
garrett
it doesn't give you any specific
information about who he is where he's
from
uh even what his motivations are other
than
there's a little bit of you know fantasy
you know about slaves and the afterlife
and so forth
but the key to this translation brian
is really it becomes into play if you
actually figure out who
the zodiac is for the record the fbi
gives credit officially to these amateur
slus and says the case remains
an ongoing investigation that's this
week i'm brian ross investigates brian
back to you thanks for the update brian
ross and now joining me is criminal
defense attorney and former prosecutor
mike corbonics
along with terry austin mike what are
your initial thoughts
as you see only the second cipher by the
zodiac killer being cracked
i just think it's amazing brian i mean
when you think about
how one goes about and how when he was
speaking about
breaking this code or deciphering i
believe the correct phrases
the amount of time that goes into this
years years of not getting anywhere and
it's finally broken
um i i don't know how evidentially it
helps the case but it sure is
is an amazing persistence in the
investigation
now terry so far the cracking of these
cyphers feels
at least to me like a giant game of cat
and mouse but
million dollar question who do you think
the cat is here
well brian if the cat represents the
authorities and the mouse represents the
killer
then i think the mouse has gotten away
you know these crimes happened back
in 1968 1969 that was a long time ago
that means that the killer is in his 70s
and 80s or maybe
even he's deceased at this point i think
you know deciphering these codes is
great but i wish we had some dna
evidence
like there was in the golden state
killer and we found out
it was joseph d'angelo i think without
that we might not ever solve this puzzle
and the hope is that a crack grows and
grows and grows until the point
that a crack leads them to something
that can identify
this killer of course we're going to
keep following this case and more
but now to new york where dramatic video
shows police officers stopping a gunman
in front of a church surveillance video
captured the moment as
christmas caroling in front of a church
in manhattan's upper west side came to
an end
as shots rang out the nypd says the
suspect fired
from the steps no individuals were hit
three nearby officers responded to the
scene
and fired back a total of 15 rounds the
suspect was shot in the head
and killed police say they recovered two
firearms and a bag
inside this bag was a full can of
gasoline
rope wire multiple knives
a bible and tape i think we can all
surmise the
ill intentions of the proceeds of this
man i can tell you that from the
preliminary body camera and again this
is quick
that we watched you see three officers
acting
heroic sergeant detective and police
officer
engaging an armed perpetrator putting
themselves
in harm's way to pull people that are
literally hiding behind these poles
behind me
caught in the crossfire so it is by the
grace of god today that we don't have
anyone struck
absolutely heroic and glad that no one
was hurt in that incident lawyers for
the former girlfriend of convicted sex
offender jeffrey epstein
are urging a judge to consider setting
bail terry austin has the details
thanks brian jalane maxwell is
requesting a 28.5
million dollar bail package that
includes armed guards to ensure she
won't flee
maxwell's bail arguments were unsealed
by a federal judge in manhattan
she said she's been married since 2016
and her husband would help her post the
money maxwell's attorney proposed
her release to home confinement in new
york city with electronic monitoring
a security specialist pledged one
million dollars towards the bail
and offered to protect her maxwell is
scheduled to go to trial next july
on charges she recruited and abused
girls for jeffrey epstein
brian thanks for the update terry still
ahead on law and crime daily
legal arguments in the case of a father
convicted of murdering his son
by leaving him in a hot car to die but
first
we take you inside the search for a
missing three-year-old
his mother dead her boyfriend arrested
where
could he be
[Music]
a woman in cincinnati was murdered and a
search is underway for her
three-year-old son
who's missing a lawn crimes anginate
levy tells us more
about the efforts to find nilo
yeah brian this is such a heartbreaking
case natia lattimore was found
stabbed to death last weekend and now
her three-year-old son
is missing now sadly nilo has not been
seen since at least
last saturday her um vladimir's body was
found early that morning near a bridge
over the ohio river
a stroller she used for nilo was found
nearby
and lattimore's boyfriend deshawn brown
is in jail
charged with murdering her vladimir as i
had mentioned had been stabbed to death
at her apartment now homicide detectives
were back at the ohio river as
searchers and canine handlers with north
star searching recovery scoured the area
looking for any sign of nilo
we're out here searching for nylo little
boy
and i'm a mom i'm a four-year-old so
this means a lot to me and just praying
that we find him and
bring him home to his family
now some of the people who are out
searching for nylon lattimore are former
police officers while others
are volunteers who've had family members
go missing in the past
whether he has passed or he is alive
hopefully alive
we're hoping to find him and at least
give if not give the family the child
back
at least give them some type of closure
in addition
we're helping the police we use a gps
location so all our searchers have a gps
on them
we use a mapping system where it records
every place that we've been we can give
that to the police department and they
can be sure that that area has
been completely covered everybody's out
here from both teams
they're all volunteers a lot of them
took off work to come here on their own
time
and everything that you you see around
us we've all put our own money in
uh it's it's we get no donations we
strictly
run on our own stuff
now in court documents police say they
actually filed that murder charge based
on witness statements and physical and
video evidence
i spoke with a spokesperson today with
the cincinnati police department he said
they are very concerned for nilo's
safety
and they hope to find him brian and
jeanette is there any criminal history
between the victim and the defendant
here
you know brian i looked through some
court records and the only thing i could
find
was a case back in may of this year
there was a report
that deshawn um had gone to uh
mishisha lattimore's apartment she
wanted him to leave
and police say when they arrived during
that altercation
that he gave a fake name and false
information
at the time it's very interesting he was
actually on probation for an assault in
another county so that might explain why
he gave that false information gotcha
thanks angenet and we're hoping that
young nilo is found
joining me now to break down the legal
side of this case are attorneys
terry austin and mike corbonix terry
a tragic killing amplified by a search
for a young child
i cringe to ask the question but do you
think
nilo will be found unharmed well you
know
i'm thinking the same thing that you are
thinking unfortunately you know it's
been several days
since he's gone missing they don't have
any clues they don't have any
information
and you saw there in the clip that they
are searching furiously for him
and so unless there is a relative that
maybe he can be
at that house i think that they might
find that uh he's now
probably deceased like his mom now
mike we've kind of seen this in the day
bell case where children are missing
we're hoping we're praying but days and
days go by
uh i guess maybe we're just looking for
the family to get some closure as the
retired officers said there but could
you see a double homicide on the horizon
for this boyfriend if the child is never
found
well we've seen it before brian i know
we've covered it on long crime it's
highly unusual because the very fact the
body's never recovered always leads
one to think there could be reasonable
doubt as to where that child is
it's just such a sad and complicated
issue
with this because you wonder if the
child was alive you would think that
maybe
the defendant would try to make some
sort of deal if the evidence is
overwhelming on the other murder to say
listen
if i tell you where this child's all
right and okay is
you know could you give me something for
that information as far as a plea deal
but
it just doesn't sound that way and it's
just very complicated
yeah and i mean we got to follow the
facts here i know the stats and the
numbers typically say
a child especially that young missing
for this long
it's kind of heartbreaking because you
fear for the worse but but the hope is
that we find nilo soon
when we come back a father convicted of
killing his son by leaving him in a hot
car
gets a second chance in court wise
defense is going after his first
attorney
next
[Music]
a georgia father convicted of killing
his son by leaving
him in a hot car is arguing for a new
trial a jury found justin ross harris
guilty of murdering 22 month old cooper
harris was sentenced to life in prison
without parole
cooper's lifeless body was found in the
car seat in harris's suv
seven hours after he parked
investigators say
temperatures reached into the high 80s
his new defense team says his trial
attorney was inadequate but the trial
attorney defends his original strategy
the state had suggested a motive that
ross wanted to
uh basically live child free
uh in order to pursue uh extramarital
sexual liaisons and um
we we we determined um throughout the
course of preparation that there was no
um objective evidence of such a motive
and as it turns out what the state
really had we felt what they had and
what they were putting up to
sort of carry that motive was bad
character evidence
some very misleading uh false testimony
of
the law enforcement officers and experts
but in a case like this
you know there's a there's a dead baby
we certainly believed that it was
incumbent upon us to
prove that the law enforcement officers
were not credible
that the state's experts were um were
not credible
uh that you know they were they were
lying to uh sort of fit their narrative
the defense's motion for a new trial
hinges on the trial attorney's decision
not to call an esteemed memory expert to
testify but the trial attorney says he
didn't call the expert
because his notes could have looked
suspicious
we were arguing that there was
absolutely no search history whatsoever
for anything
like children left in cars how hot does
a car have to be
divorce lawyers there was nothing like
that there was no search which supported
the uh the state's suggestion of motive
objectively there just wasn't anything
there this line in here knowledge of how
to erase internet search history
at the very least at the very least it's
it demonstrates that the defense team
and the defense
expert is concerned about it is worried
about it is looking into it is asking
about it
notes that could have looked suspicious
mike what do you make of that
excuse or reasoning by the defense
attorney and does it hold water
uh it doesn't hold water to me because
there's two things you could do in that
situation
is if you don't agree with your expert
you could ask the court
prior to trial you should have those
reports judge i need an adjournment
there's something we need to do
in our defense you can even do it in
camera because something is
gonna miss in your defense i don't i
don't think it's a strong argument
now terry to you agree or disagree on
how these notes might have looked
you know i agree with mike i don't think
they look suspicious here and i think
that they could have gone
in and he could have called dr diamond
because dr diamond would have really
helped the case
i think he could have redacted the notes
so they looked better rather than
looking like the defense was leading him
yeah or
do your job as a defense attorney
explain things to the jury so it's not
incriminating but we'll see how that
plays out
when we come back cross-examination of
this attorney
why prosecutors say justin ross harris
got a fair trial
and shouldn't be given a new one after
the break
back now to arguments over whether a
father convicted of murdering his son
after leaving him in a hot car for hours
should get a new trial
prosecutors say justin ross harris
deliberately left his 22 month old
sonnet cooper
in his car and did not simply forget him
there
and the defense calling a certain memory
expert would not have changed that
what he would have testified to was yes
this
in this case uh it is my opinion that
what happened was a result
of a memory failure now uh mr donakowski
that
that said i doubt very seriously that
mr boring would have asked that specific
question to dr diamond because
that probably goes to the ultimate issue
so if dr diamond would have testified
we would have phrased the questions to
him more along the line of so the
what what you observed and evaluated
in this case was it consistent
with what you know about
memory failure was this case consistent
with your study of memory failure
the court had ruled that no expert could
give their opinion
of the ultimate issue if the case was
due to memory loss
in your opinion wouldn't the state have
objected
to that testimony given he's basically
saying well susie shoplifted in this
manner so therefore
janet had to have shoplifted it wasn't
accidental that she put it in her purse
because susie did it this way and
wouldn't the state have objected to that
sort of
testimony so we're talking about the
testimony of an expert
who is giving his opinion based on uh
all of his work all of his study and his
study
is studying these very cases um so i i
i think that it's certainly within the
um
certainly within the realm of the expert
to give that very testimony
but but to answer your question ms
donkowski
uh i think the state was going to object
to everything
as they did throughout the entire trial
anything
anything they didn't want the jury to
hear they were going to come up with
some sort of objection
hearsay foundation whatever
so yeah they were probably going to
object
on redirect the defense asked the
attorney why he believes police were
lying
in to the court some of the search
warrants were
requested immediately immediately
following the interview with ross harris
and they contained references to the
interview with ross harris
those references contained statements
which were false
they said that ross harris had stated or
ross harris had said
certain things that in fact he had not
said and he had not stated
they were attributing um uh
false statements to him
all right so i'm kind of on the fence
here and i think being the middle of the
two of you makes it perfect here
uh terry let's come to you first is
there anything in this hearing that
makes you
think harris does not deserve another
trial
no i think he does deserve another trial
listen
i don't think there was ineffective
counsel i think the council made
some strategic moves not all right but i
don't think he was ineffective
what i do think is that there was
evidence that shouldn't have gotten in
like these witnesses who testified about
his sexual
you know habits and i do think that he
was limited on his examination of the
police officers for those reasons
i think he should get a new trial all
right mike i want you to answer the
opposite end of that coin
and help us out here what factor
argument tells you
that we should not get a new trial here
not many but i will step in to uh try to
be a creative and go back in time as a
prosecutor
i i do believe that the arguments
about the expert on not calling him
those are clearly clearly within the
discretion of the defense
and i don't think it's ineffective my
biggest problem with this case like i
said is i think the judge
really didn't do a very good job in
letting all the 404 evidence in
which was the the sex thing things of
that nature because i still
no matter how you stretch and see where
the relevance is and as a prosecutor
i wouldn't have pushed that so i could
get a conviction that would stick
yeah it's going to be interesting to see
how this plays out and i agree with you
guys there seems to be stronger
arguments
when it comes to this this paramore this
sex worker testifying
that he wanted to live child free it
didn't seem to really work out but we'll
see how it plays out
mike terry thank you for joining us as
always and thank you for joining us here
on law and crime daily we'll see you
next time as we discuss justice in
[Music]
america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you